تنضمي لان الفنانه جوري قطاني يسعد صباحك
يا جوري يسعد صباحك شكرا على تواجدك معنا
والف مبروك على هذا الفوز بالجائزه القيمه
جائزه الوجه الشاب المفضل في هذا الحفل
الكبير
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا اهلا يا جوري اولا كيف كان
شعورك بالفوز باعلان اسمك قدام الجمهور
كله في هذا الحفل الكبير لفئه الموسيقيه
اه
بصراحه اول اول يعني ما قالوا اسمي او اول
مره راغب علامه قال اسمي ما كنت متوقعه
ولكن كنت يعني حاطه يقين انه انا راح اطلع
على المسرح راح اتجوز بس ما كنت متوقعه
يعني
يعني ما ادري بس مره مره فرحت
والحمد لله جوري انت كمان بحديثك خصيتي
والدك ووالدتك قد ايه كانوا دعم اساسي في
حياته الموهبه بشكل عام تسقل وتدعم من
البيت اولا
صحيح
اه انا ذكرت بالاخص بابا وماما لانهم من
جدهم اللي وقفوا معي همم هم اللي دعموني
عشان احقق حلمي فا
اقول لهم من كل قلبي شكرا شكرا انكم طلعت
فنانه سعوديه اسمها جوري قطان طيب جوري
يعني رغم الموهبه الكبيره والصوت الجميل
الذي اشاد به الكثير في الوسط الفني لانه
جوري ليست معروفه يعني كثيرا يعني هل بسبب
صغر سنك هل بسبب قله اعمالك حدثيني اكثر
عن جوري
بصراحه اه
يعني احدثك اكثر عن جوري جوري
شخصيه جدا يعني اكلمك عشان شخصيه شخصيه
جدا
في الشغل عمليه وما اتكلم انه جوري بسنها
تشتغل لا انا في العمل او في الشغل بالاصح
يعني
مو على عمري
اكبر من عمري بس انه زي كده في الشغل
عشان مليون خاطر
من عيوني
بس يقول ابغى وانا اقول
حاضر
انت الوحيد
اللي كلامك
اوامر
وخاطرك
عندي ترى
مو مثل غيرك
وخاطره
مليون خا
يسلم هالصوت يا جوري يعني فعلا طب جوري
راح تكسفي باللهجه الخليجيه باغانيكي
واعمالك الفنيه القادمه ولا ممكن نشوف
جوري بلهجه مختلفه تماما
لا طبعا طبعا رح اغني لهجات ثانيه واصلا
انا بغني لهجات ثانيه يعني بما اني شاركت
في برنامجين وفي البرنامج اللي شاركت فيهم
اللي هم النجم السعوديه وبرنامج بوليفارد
المواهب اااه في البرنامجين هذه انا طلعت
مواهبي وكمان وريت الناس انه انا اقدر
اغني بكل اللهجات بكل الالوان يعني سوري
اه بصراحه الملحنين اللي تعاملت معاهم
الملحن والى الان انا تعامل معاه وان شاء
الله رح ينزل عمل قريب ان شاء الله اللي
هو الملحن الكبير الاستاذ ناصر الصالح
فهو اكثر شخص او اوجه رساله هو اكثر شخص
دعمني من الملحنين
وان شاء الله لنا اعمال قادمه جميله وهي
اغنيه على حسب اغنيه الجديد اللي نزلت على
راس السنه هي من الحان الاستاذ نصر الصالح
انه يراهن على الجوري بقوه شفتي تصريحات
صح
صح ايوه جوري
جوري في اغنيه بتحب تغنيها للفنان اخر او
فنانه اخرى
اه ايوه طب شو حابه تسمعينا كمان هيك
بصوتك
[موسيقى]
يا طيب القلب وينك
مشتاق لك يا حياتي
اسيره يدك
وينك الشوق عيني
له عين اتخيلك
في مجرى والهدا
يشين ديك الزوا
ق من غير طال عاد
جبينك الشوق عيني لع
ين للفنان القدير
اه مال القادم ان شاء الله هينزل البوم من
الحان ناصر الصالح كمان بس ما بصرح عليه
اكثر ابغاكم تتفاجئوا وتستمتعوا بالعمل
الجاي اكيد ان شاء الله بالتوفيق جوري بس
جوري انت لسه صبيه صغيره واول مشوارك
الفني رسمتي شو بدك بهالدنيا لوين بدك
توصلي الى اين
ااه شوفي انا اقول دائما انه الشخص اللي
بده ينجح او يغير سنه طريق ما يفكر الين
يعني الين خط معين او نقطه معينه تفكير
يكون دائما للبعيد
وخط ما له نهايه
انا راسمه انه انا ان شاء الله راح اوصل
وراح احقق حلمي وووو
وهيشوف الناس انه جوري قطان كيف هتصير
اتمنى لك كل التوفيق جوري نسمع منك شيء
اخير يكون مسك الختان لبرنامجنا اشكرك على
وجودك جوري
الله يسعدك
على حسب يمكن احن يمكن انساك
وشميتي للحين الله اعلم ما ودي استعجل
واصرح بفرقاك ما ودي ارجع لك وبعدين انت
[موسيقى]
في امان الله جوري شكرا لك